[Music]
so honest text but I think they can hear
us I think so
apparently so I'm so pleased to have you
here
pleased to be with you yeah Anish Kapoor
I think most of you know sir Anish
Kapoor is one of the most visible and
prominent and in my view important
visual artists working today and in many
ways he defines what contemporary art
can be so I will not go into all the
exhibitions and important recognitions
I would just get started with our
Siemens young and I think that for both
of us
I'm MSC museum director and not for a
science museum for an art museum this is
a little bit of a not old but new
territory we're surrounded by people
linked to the Noble Foundation and who
are mainly working in the in the
academic or the scientific field and we
are in the art world and just to begin
with a tiny tiny question namely the
question of truth oh it's very small
yeah I would ask is there such a thing
what is the role of truth in art can an
artwork be true yeah of course that's a
very very difficult difficult question
so in preparation I've been reading
Freud where else would one go and Freud
has a very interesting attitude to truth
in that of course psychoanalytically
speaking of course where is it what is
it and the NEB the nebulous nosov it is
something that we take as it's hard for
us to accept that actually it is
nebulous and we can't we continue if we
keep looking for it here and there so I
would go immediately from Freud to
another great man which is who
Sushil who said who said I think very
deeply very profoundly the artist is a
mediumistic being I like this idea of
the mediumistic being so we are already
calling a kind of cabal of the
shamanistic or whatever it is
so the mediumistic being who seeks
mystic truth but but and this is the key
thing but the work itself is never
complete until the viewer is present so
mediumistic being makes this object and
then in this interaction something takes
place that completes the work truth lies
in this interaction and of course its
nebulous because I come with my
love-hate desire do I want it how much
does it cost and all the other crap that
life brings and says oh is it not so
interesting no I don't believe it
oh yes I do believe it and of course the
eye of all our instruments I believe is
the quickest sharpest most knowing you
walk into the room and you know it's
good but it's not good it's real or it's
not real you just know so where does
knowing come from isn't it the case in
in in your field which is primarily that
of sculpture that it's about materials
that you can be true to your discipline
you can be true to your be it stone or
wood door isn't that at this force yeah
when I was a student it was a big thing
truth to material
yeah uh-huh I always thought such
I'm afraid yeah I hope you'll
agree with me truth to material you know
this sense that a thing is a thing
because of its thickness well what we
know about the world is that it's not I
can't be defined by my thickness it just
doesn't look I have an inner kind of
empty space
black space fear death where did I come
where was i before I was born where do I
go after I'm dead
that is true of that object as it is
true of me and you know that wonderful
high daguerreian moment of you know
taking a lump of clay turning it into a
pot it was a lump of play now it's a pot
suddenly a new existence but it was
there the pot nurse if you like was
there in the clay that what I've tried
to say is that there's no such thing as
truth to material good to hear that the
other the other aspect then not the work
but the artist an artist can be true to
him or herself no or at least I know I
have the feeling that certain artists
are kind of sometimes a little bit
selling out because there's political
expectations or financial like you know
we all know when we feel that that's not
really you're not really true to
yourself and what does it mean to be
true to yourself what does that mean in
your world well I mean I think being an
artist is about having a practice it's
not about I'm going to make a more or
less beautiful thing you know who gives
a beautiful thing not a beautiful
thing
ah it's a pain it's a pain but a
practice is something else where you you
know um I mean so many great artists
that we think of had this discipline
that was the practice Picasso may have
to had a flamboyant life but it was the
think studio every day 10 works a day
hundred works a day whatever it was do
it do it do it so meaning comes out of
that action comes out of that beautiful
not beautiful comes out of that this
thing of the repeated process so a
practice is and and I think that is to
do with Ron norick and coherence yeah
but there are moments of course when
it's all over the place when I do you
know artists are all bloody irrelevant
you know at one level and the côte d --n
the day every day life
is more or less boring more or less so
how does one hold on to a deep and real
practice to go to your question about
being true to yourself what is it isn't
it filled with banality and filled with
ordinariness so how does one excavate
the you know I'll tell you a little
story when I was a teenager I had a
terrible difficult in a time whatever
depression or whatever my mother who was
a rather wonderful woman said you know
what you need we need to get some earth
and put it under your bed earth under
your bed there's a little typical Indian
thing okay so some earth was got and put
under my bed of course it didn't make
the slightest bit of difference but I've
lived with it ever since that there is
if you like this shamanistic mythical
under life that we're really after
that's what being an artist is about
it's about that sense that in the
ordinary is the uncanny of course I keep
coming back to Freud
I very first works I saw of yours long
long long before I met you and where
there were definitely always a sense of
wonder and and mystery and even you know
were you an uncertainty where you
wouldn't be sure if what you saw was a
kind of piece of velvet a flat thing or
maybe a empty space and a kind of
mysterious cavity and almost to do with
illusionism actually I mean maybe we
should what would you say if I say that
a heart has nothing to do with truth
it's more about poetics poetry and
illusions yeah but it may be the deep
truth is in the Unreal then it's a
deeper truth than the apparently real
are we looking for
there's a wonderful Greek word which is
if I can say it up of the apathy
catharsis which means going to the
beginning of things is it possible for
us to go to the beginning to point at
matter as it originates in some in some
real what is consciousness I mean
science is good at lots of things hasn't
done a hell of a lot about consciousness
but can we talk about that so you asked
me about illusionism I've made lots of
physical objects but I'm really not
interested in physicality what I've
discovered in the process of making the
work is that every object contains a
kind of non object you know in the glass
it's probably that thing there so what
is the non what is this question of how
the physical relates to some other
possible reality perhaps the ground is
is large and flat but if you make a big
hole in it and fill it with darkness
it's not a hole it's not just a cave
it's filled with darkness and that has
to be visceral and real whatever that is
then it does something then it this
there's the question of what is present
and what is absent what is physical
could it be that that black thing is
more physical I think there's a there
was a picture of it of it up here some
point some minutes ago but is it that
it's more real than the ground on which
you stand so it's to do with fundamental
things with roots with the the beginning
of things you say when you create these
works can we dare to go there I mean can
we aim that high do we have to limit
ourselves to what is actually knowable
I think we need to dare to say that
without those aspirations much humanity
is missing sorry I interrupted you know
I'm listening and I'm thinking you
quoted this famous quote from Marcel
Duchamp who talked about the artist as a
medium and maybe mystic being somehow
receiving I don't know what message is
inspirational impulses from somewhere
outside of time and space he says I
remember and what how do you prepare
yourself for that
well you can't wake up in the morning
and say I'm gonna make something
beautiful today oh I'm gonna make
something spiritual today you can't what
you can do is yeah I've been in
psychoanalysis for 25 years
sadly or gladly whatever one thing I've
discovered about the process is that you
lie there with your analysts and if
they're any good and if you're any good
things emerge it's almost as if in this
process there's the two of you and then
suddenly before you know it there's a
third being and that being becomes the
matter that is the cause and effect of a
conversation it's not disabled in the
studio so in the studio it doesn't
matter what you make the point is to
make the point is to be there and
practice in practice something emerges
if it doesn't come from the ether I mean
yes okay Marcel lovely but actually it's
in practice then you've made the thing
or half made the thing then it's the
moment of reflection to say what is this
thing does it have a meaning can it
become mythological in other words what
is what is the the transformative act
that I need to almost consciously make
to Britt to drag this object into a
poetic reality and I think that's an act
of experience of culture of
consciousness so from the unconscious if
you like dragged into the conscious and
given a placing reality I think that
that is what an artist is after all not
the first part that's a lovely first
part but it's that second part that says
a watch I'll do and then I will act and
it's in that process that real content
real meaning arises I didn't sit there
and dream up some black hole you know it
happened to me in the most bizarre way
but it happened I didn't dream it in
compare the methodology of a studio
artist of someone working with others in
the studio to scientific methods I mean
in a sense you are you have a keen
interest in certain optical phenomena I
know that and you are very knowledgeable
when it comes to light and darkness and
certain pigments and how they absorb
light and it it does have a scientific
aspect also now deeply interested
technology you know I've been working
with this deepest black for the last few
to three years and it happened in
another in a strange way I read a little
article in newspaper in which somebody
who worked in the South of England
claimed to have found the blackest
material in the universe you know not
absorbed 99.8% of all light so I gave
him a call and said can I work with you
on this he said no but it has no visual
application you know we make it for the
defense industry so anyway we managed to
offer quite a lot of persuasion to get
going together it's a highly technical
interesting a material that absorbs
what's what's so interesting well I'll
tell you it's highly technical process
so
there were two great discoveries in the
in the Renaissance one we know about his
perspective but there's another one
which is not much talked about which is
the fold the fold yeah all that all
those especially the early Renaissance
all those wonderful bits of cloth
what is the fold the perspective places
the the viewer at the center and of
course the world away diminishing the
fold speaks of being speaks of the body
itself of being of present Ness
well this material if you have it on a
piece of cloth paper you do that
whatever you like you can't see the fold
so in my small way I say it's beyond
being that's the real interest is that
there's this stuff that has a kind of
it's a kind of hyper material
it's beyond material and it weird weird
phenomena how can I not work with
[Laughter]
fragile that you could hardly breathe in
its presence and I mean that especially
to saliva and oh so it's a nightmare but
anyway I've entered this this this
studio practice and how you work with
these relatively complex things some
artists run big studios this is nothing
new
and you have a I had the privilege of
visiting you in this studio once and I
know you have a big studio with lots of
complex processes wrong it's that it's
just I mean how collective is that is
that like in laboratory sit in the end
how would you do wall I will not be a
worker in my own factory so and it is
very very important that we you know the
art world is so driven by production and
so driven by a kind of economy one has
to be absolutely clear that that is a
wonderful spin off of the main practice
the way I wrote the way I have my studio
I have about 20 people who work with me
sculpture is a long process it doesn't
happen you know you make a painting in a
day or two or three the sculpture it
takes weeks and months so we are working
in sometimes together me and the people
that I that I work with but I spending
most of my day alone so I have another
part of the studio which is alone I find
it absolutely necessary to have my own
if you like psychic space that isn't
collaborative it's it's a weird thing
that because in collaboration there is
real creative energy but personally I
find I need to remove myself from it to
some extent I mean the question of truth
in art is complicated and maybe also the
notion of knowledge is difficult I just
recently read a quote by someone who's
very relevant relevant in this context
because he won the Nobel Prize in
Literature Naipaul from from your
country who said that and the sciences
help us to gain knowledge of the world
but art helps us to get knowledge of
ourselves that's a grand statement but
would you agree that there is something
to that yes I think most artists I mean
there I be so so bold
will you forgive me but I think most
artists have too much to say I mean I've
talked too much but I hope as an artist
I don't have to too much or even
anything to say I've often repeated that
and try to repeat it to myself often you
have nothing to say you have nothing to
say and in nothing to say I think it
allows content to emerge
that wouldn't be there otherwise if I
had something to say that I just say it
it's done then I can say goodbye but
it's that it's the ability of a thing or
a process to come into meaning that I'm
interested in does that tell us about
being I think it does you see so maybe
they poles right truth as far as it goes
the deepest truths are those about
ourselves clearly but the root is never
straight there's this lovely Indian
thing if you're trying to catch your
nose don't catch it like that catch it
like that yeah
say things about your work rather than
just accept that what you have to say is
what you want to say is in the work I
mean sometimes people like myself or I
mean writers or critics or curators want
artists to talk rather than to do their
job it's someone made fun of fun of the
whole situation saying it's like asking
Miles Davis after a concert please mr.
Davis what was the meaning of your
concert I hope this is not quite that
you know it is mythological I mean one
hopes that it is mythological and or
rather that is the purpose and talking
sometimes helps to unravel some part of
a mythological process the object as it
as it leaves me has to find its own life
it doesn't it's not me I go when you
talk about logical dimensions and and
and fundamental levels it could be maybe
understood or misunderstood as if you
were not interested in our contemporary
world however I know you are very much
and we have another little session in a
few minutes talking about something
which might be surprising that you're
working with the most high-tech of
things also in the in the technological
communication world namely virtual
reality what why are you interested in
such new
medium is such a new medium where no
artists has done their famous work yet I
mean there there are people trying and
you're one of the very very first what's
interesting it's very difficult medium I
mean virtual is fine we can deal with
virtual or somewhat deal with virtual
reality is really problematic especially
when it's translated through technology
and what we find what I found in working
with it now for a few months is that
it's the reality part that you can't
quite grasp so the physicalness of the
apparent experience is this wonderful
it's a wonderful illusion that happens
completely in your head I've also
noticed that it has one physical
attribute real physical attribute even
though it's unreal and that is vertigo
that you stand there with this thing on
and your your propensity to fall is huge
so the T genus the falling of the self
and of course all experiences over the
sublime are like this you know we don't
have to read can't too deeply to
understand that they are virtually the
same thing this so this poetic moment of
falling has something in it that is some
profound and virtual reality does it in
quite an interesting way maybe you are
about the new medium called virtual
unreality we will see so even if it's
only prototype or first chapter I know
yeah it's actually worth premiere right
here with our saturday.and I know you
are also showing the piece so Serena
SHhhh I want to thank you so much for
this with us thank you for coming all
the way to Sweden thank you so much
thank you thank you
[Applause]